in this video we will discuss what a
full factorial design is how to create
one and how to analyze the results a
full factorial design is a systematic
method for examining the effects and the
possible interactions of several factors
on a response variable the aim is to
analyze the relationship between several
input variables and an output variable
the input variables of the system are
called factors and the output variable
is called response variable of course
there can also be several response
variables therefore factors are the
variables believ to affect the response
each factor now has at least two levels
these levels are the specific values a
factor can take and we want to find out
whether a change in the levels of the
factors has an influence on the response
let's look at an example when you paddle
a bike the wheels rotate around a
central Rod known as the axle to ensure
that the wheel can spin there are
bearings now imagine you're paddling
your bike on a smooth road if the
bearings are in good condition the
wheels will spin easily the so-called
frictional torque in this case is low if
the bearing is not in a good condition
you have to push harder to keep the same
speed because there's more frictional
torque with the help of a full factorial
design we would now like to find out
what influences the frictional torque of
a bearing in this case of course the
frictional torque is our Target variable
possible factors could be lubrication or
temperature for lubrication there could
be the factor levels oiled and greased
and for temperature there could be the
levels low medium and high now we want
to know what influence the different
levels have on the response variable a
full factorial design can help us here
especially if we have not just two but
three four or five variables a full
factorial design can lead to Great
savings depending on the field of study
the system under investigation can be a
process a machine or a product but of
course also humans for example if you
want to investigate the influence of
medication but now we still have four
open questions how to estimate the
number of experiments needed how does a
full factorial design work how can a
full factorial design help to reduce the
number of experiments how to analyze the
results let's start with the first
question experiments cost time and money
the number of runs should therefore be
kept as small as possible but beware if
the number of runs is too small there is
a high risk that relevant differences
will not be recognized let's take a look
at our example we would like to
investigate which factors have an
influence on the frictional torque of a
bearing let's start with one factor
lubrication we would like to know
whether it has an influence on the
frictional torque if a bearing is oiled
or greased to find out we take a random
sample of 10 bearings we oil one half of
the bearings and grease the other half
now we can measure the frictional torque
of the five oil bearings and the five re
bearings but stop why 10 bearings in
most cases each run costs a lot of money
perhaps we can manage with fewer runs so
how many experiments do we need in order
to find out if the lubricant has an
effect on the frictional torque let's
just start with 10 bearings we can now
calculate the mean value of the
frictional torque of the oiled and
greased bearings then we can calculate
the difference between the two mean
values in this sample we can see that
there is a difference between oiled and
greased however we can already see that
the frictional torque in the oiled and
greased bearings is highly scattered if
we take another random sample of 10
bearings it is possible that this time
the difference will be greater but it is
also possible that the difference will
be in exactly the opposite direction in
other words the frictional torque of the
bearings scatters the wi the spread the
more difficult it is to identify a
specific difference or effect
fortunately the variability of the mean
value can be reduced by increasing the
sample size the larger the sample size
the more precise is the estimation of
the mean therefore the smaller the
effect and The Wider the spread of the
response variable the larger the sample
needs to be but how much larger how can
you estimate the number of runs needed
you can use this formula as an
approximation here n is the number of
runs Sigma is the standard deviation and
Delta is the effect to be determined for
example if we have a standard deviation
of 3 Newton mm and a difference of 5
Newton mm is relevant for us then we
need 22 runs if we only have a standard
deviation of 2 Newton mm we only need 10
runs and with a standard deviation of
one newton mm we get 2.4 so we need two
runs with greased bearings and two runs
with oil bearings but how can a full
factorial design help you reduce the
number of experiments let's assume that
the calculation of the number of runs
results in 16 experiments so eight runs
with oil bearings and eight runs with
grease bearings but what if we have a
second Factor let's say in addition to
lubrication we have temperature with low
and high then we need another eight runs
to take this factor into account so we
need 16 runs to check if the lubricant
has an effect and 16 runs to check if
the temperature has an effect this gives
us a total of 24 runs now the question
arises is it possible to achieve this
with fewer runs and that brings us to
the full factorial design the question
is why should we limit ourselves to
testing one factor at a time instead we
could devise a design that incorporates
the fourth potential combination which
is grease and high temperature of course
we still need 16 runs per Factor we get
this by making four runs with each of
the four combinations then we have eight
runs with oil and eight with grease and
on the other side eight with low
temperature and eight with high
temperature we now have a total of 16
runs before that we had 24 runs we now
need fewer experiments and get even more
information why more information we now
also know whether there is an
interaction between temperature and
lubrication for example oil bearings may
show A variation in frictional torque at
different temperatures which is not
observed with greased bearings this
information would have been lost
previously now when we have three
factors instead of two the savings are
even higher if we test one of the three
factors at a time we need 32 runs if we
now run two experiments for each
combination in a full factorial design
we still only need 16 runs however for
each factor we still have eight tests
per Factor level for example for the
lubrication Factor we have eight runs
with oil and AD runs with grease of
course we can also create full factorial
designs with more than two levels for
example the temperature Factor could
have three Factor levels low medium and
high however even with a full factorial
designed with two levels in each factor
the number of runs required increases
very quickly as the number of factors
increases in a full factorial design the
number of experiments or runs is n equal
to 2 to the power of K where n is the
number of runs and K is the number of
factors here is a small overview if we
have three factors for example we have
to make at least eight runs with seven
factors it is already at least 128 runs
and with 10 factors it is already at
least 1,24 runs therefore full factorial
designs are generally only used up to a
maximum of six or seven factors please
note that this table applies to a full
factorial design where each factor only
has two levels otherwise there will be
even more runs and now I'll show you how
you can create a full factorial design
online with data Tab and how you can
then analyze and interpret the results
to do this simply go to data.net click
on plus and then on
doe here you can choose which type of
design you want to create we want to
create a full factorial design in this
case we assume that each factor has only
two levels in the second case there is
no restriction and you can Define the
number of levels for each factor we will
simply use the design with two levels
next we can find the number of factors
we take three factors and now we can
Define the names and the values of the
factor levels let's say temperature with
low and high lubrication with oil and
grease and material with steel and
caramic now we can see the created test
plan each row is now an experiment the
first experiment we do for example with
temperature low with lubrication oil and
material deal if we want we can still
choose to order randomly so that there
is as little influence as possible
regarding the order depending on how
many runs we need we can determine the
number of applications we'll just take
two each combination is now performed
twice so we don't have eight runs but 16
now we can export the table to Exel and
carry out the individual experiments we
then write down the friction torque
obtained for each experiment note this
values are just fictional once we have
performed all experiments we can copy
the data back to data Tab and analyze
them to do this we click on doe analysis
and then select all factors and the
target value now we can click on the two
Factor interactions and the three Factor
interaction we now get the regression
coefficients with coded values the paror
diagram the regression coefficients with
uncoded values and the results of the
analysis of variance what is the
difference between coded and uncoded
regression coefficients in our example
we have categorical Factor levels if we
copy these into Data tab data tab simply
numbers the different categories with
values for the temperature factor for
example the category low has the value
one and high the value two of course we
can also change this we can also give
low the value minus one and high the
value one and this is exactly what is
done automatically with the coded
coefficients here the categories are
automatically set to minus one and one
how are the results interpreted the
first step is to analyze which factors
and interactions have a significant
influence on the frictional torque a
factor interaction has a statistically
significant influence if the P value in
this table is smaller than
0.05 in this case the temperature Factor
has a P value of less than
0.05 as well as the lubrication and the
material all main effects therefore have
a significant influence on the
frictional torque we can also see that
the interaction between temperature and
lubrication also has a significant
influence however the other interactions
have a P value of
0.5 which is greater than
0.05 so these interactions have no
significant influence on the frictional
torque exactly the same can be seen in
this par diagram in the diagram the
amount of the T value is plotted for
temperature for example the value of T
is
2616 which we can also see in the table
above the red line indicates the
critical T value I.E Above This value we
obtain a P value of less than
0.05 and there for a significant value
the results show that the last three
interactions are not significant in
order to obtain the final results the
nonsignificant factors and interactions
are now removed from the model so we
remove these three interactions from the
model we've now created our model and
determined the significant factors and
interactions in addition data tab
displays the results in diagrams and you
can view the results of the analysis of
variance finally the optimal input
parameters can be calculated ated in
order to minimize or maximize the target
value of course this makes particular
sense if we have matric factors which in
the best case have been measured with
three Factor levels each I hope you
enjoyed the video and see you next
time